[Music]
so as we get started
not everyone knows how the committee
works or what the committee is there was
a question that was asked in person and
one of our prep events that it seemed
quite obvious but it is a great question
to start with what's the organization
behind tc39 Oh check we have my check
here we go I am part of the chair group
for for 2019 I work for PayPal and
Braintree and tc39 is the 39th Technical
Committee of an organization by the name
of ACMA International aqua does is a
standards body like you know ISO or that
kind of thing and they publish the
standard that we work on as a committee
and so that's the organization behind
tc39 and the committee itself is made up
of people who are sent by member
organizations that companies and
nonprofits who are part of ACMA so we
are all considered delegates we are we
either work for or are associated with
these companies that are part of echo
international so we we work together and
collaborate on what goes into the spec
and how we're going to be able to make
improvements and changes and support all
the different ways that javascript is
used Thank You Aki and the next question
that we're gonna do just to set up the
stage
what tc39 is and does is how does the
proposal actually move through the
committee now Tarr did a wonderful
introduction to our four stages but we
also have Jase here on stage who just
did a wonderful talk about his rust
engine in JavaScript and
he's been doing more work with the tc39
specifically he's been getting a
proposal through called all settled can
you talk a bit about the process of
getting such a proposal through a
committee one two so yeah I was quite
lucky to meet a lot of people on the
committee last year in London and I felt
a lot of it started off we've actually
just a conversation and talking to
various members of the committee if
there was an appetite for such a
proposal and it turns out that it was
and that was a good thing and so Daniel
has been really helpful in putting me in
contact with the right people and not
only that but those people who come from
different backgrounds as well so that's
really helped it started off by what we
call a straw person proposal which was
just a stage 0 and anybody can make that
and that was just a good Reaper with I
you know identify in the problem space
and then we managed to get a champion
for that which was Mattias who's not
here but he's from v8 and you really
helped with me on that and so stage one
was basically just identifying what is
the problem here what's the limitation
and and how he can fix it it's it's not
too important to to have a solution at
this point and so we managed to craft
something up that worked we had a we had
a very sort of small proposal that got
through Mattias championed it and we
reached stage two and then for stage 2
myself in rob family who's not here from
Bloomberg but we both work together on
some of the specification and also
getting sort of more ideas from people
as well also another good thing is after
stage 1 we had implementation from Babel
which was really good so that also helps
as well when you get feedback and then
stage 3 is more getting even more
feedback and sort of thinking about a
candidate release and luckily I don't
think there were too many sort of
rejections or limitations and most
people seem too happy with it and very
recently we made we made stage free as
well and so now I think it's it's just
getting some implementations and
browsers and people can try it in chrome
and canary and nightly and then they
spout getting more feedback and and
hopefully yes Stage four
yeah soon and you made this proposal not
as a member of the committee but as
independent contributor right yeah
absolutely I was back with the BBC at
the time and it was a limitation for me
as a JavaScript developer and I thought
well if it's a limitation for me how
many other people out there have this
limitation so one of the ways of working
that out was going to NPM seeing how
many people were downloading these
external packages and thinking other
languages have this natively is this
something that we can do in JavaScript
and like I said I was very lucky I just
contacted them everybody here was very
friendly and I had a conversation with
members of the panel and they were very
happy to champion it and we went from
there and I'm just gonna ask you to
introduce yourself in which come oh yes
sorry Jason Williams a software engineer
at Bloomberg thank you
so another question that we get
sometimes is ok so we've got this whole
proposal structure but how do we know
it's like implemented correctly in
browsers what's going on there well I'm
going to hand this over to Valerie and
if you can introduce yourself and how we
do that I hi I'm Valerie yang I work at
boku I'm an open web engineer and I I'm
also the editor of the
internationalization extension to
JavaScript called ECMO for two it's the
Intel object that does claw relation and
date/time formatting but also as part of
my work at boku I help maintain the test
to 6 - test suite which is a test suite
of the JavaScript or akima script
implementations so the test suite is
about 35,000 tests which tests though
very the the individual test which tests
JavaScript each test is a test file
which has some metadata about what line
it tests in ACMA script itself and then
each test is around twice so really
there's 70,000 tests once instructed
once in non-strict mode this is test e6
to report which is a website which shows
how well these tests are doing on all of
the four JavaScript engines chakracore
javascriptcore spider monkey and v8 and
the tests are each in an individual test
file so this is a directory structure
which rep
the test structure that you can find and
if you want to look at the source you
can drill down and look at individual
tests and whether or not they're they're
passing and see the source code on the
page of this website or you can go to
our github tc39 slashed sd-6 - and to
get a a standard in Exmouth script or a
new proposal an equi script the last
stage includes adding tests to test to
see - to test c6 - as well as browser
implementations so while the browsers
are implementing there's also test being
contributed and all of the browsers can
make sure that they're in compliance and
passing the same tests so so it's a fun
project Thank You Valerie fantastic if I
could add to that this is actually
really an awesome resource we Jason
talked about implementing a JavaScript
engine but for our major JavaScript
engines having something like this to be
able to say very easily when are we not
being spec conformant is such an immense
resource so yeah and can you introduce
yourself oh yes I'm Ross curse Lang and
I work at Playstation on our WebKit team
thank you
so this sort of rounds off our
introduction to how tc39 works we're
gonna be moving on with community
questions that you folks asked and we're
gonna start with one from last year
asked by Sam Bassin I hope I pronounced
that correctly I doubt it though he asks
I noticed the committee is very heavily
dominated by Americans and American
companies particularly Google do you
have any plans to become more
representative of the world and only
give certain companies so much power
well we are looking at how individual
companies and specifically um individual
spaces where we get together in person
are impacting those those contributions
and ACMA International which is the
organization that we are part of in fact
is currently putting an effort into
helping us find a way to be more
inclusive internationally in future
years of the 2019 meet a meetings are
all already scheduled
but 2020s being skills right now and
we're gonna we're gonna work on finding
a way to be more inclusive thank you
that was very nice answer hi I'm Daniel
Aaron Burke I work in key Galia in our
compilers team so I think there there is
a real issue of of this particular kind
of bias that was identified but I just
also want to point out that there is
heavy European involvement in the
development of the JavaScript
specification both from from people in
the munich v8 office as well as from
bloomberg and from my company Galia
based in Spain and and several others
also from from moddable
and so I think we can we can build on
that success also Yuliya of course we
think here in Berlin
yes I'm based in Germany and I'm based
in Berlin so if you have any complaints
you know where to find me
thank you both for that answer moving
along into more specific questions about
the standard we've had several questions
about how long it takes to standardize
things and when do things come out like
how long does it take for a proposal to
go from stage zero to stage four take
that one it can take a very long time I
mean the simple answer is years but if
you were to essentially you wouldn't
really expect to go through our staging
process more than one per meeting and we
we do meet every other month but you
know there's a lot to do in that
timeframe implementing in Babel will
take time for instance you may need to
of course the problem space that you're
addressing might be quite clear but the
solution might not be maybe you need to
revise that multiple times we've seen
that happen decorators might be a great
example and finally at the end of it all
we need before we can say that we're all
said and done we need this to be
implemented in at least and shipping and
at least two of the major engines and
you unless you want to implement that
yourself might not have control over
that time frame so it can take a very
long time and discussions can get very
heated and so unless you have a very
simple very uncontroversial proposal it
will probably take on the order of years
Thanks
the next question that well do we have
anyone else who wants to chime in okay
great so the next question that we have
is coming from Nicola Ranjan Ron Jana
I'm not sure and he's asking when are we
going to get a standard library for
JavaScript so from the way I see it we
already have a standard library in
JavaScript we have a bunch of functions
you know math JSON array all these maps
that JavaScript has a pretty pretty well
I was gonna say pretty big standard
library but that's just not true so I
think that's what this question is
really getting at is can we have a
bigger standard library for JavaScript
can we have more things in the standard
library for JavaScript another thing
that people often bring up in this
context is you know should we put the
standard library in modules instead of
where we're currently putting it which
is in Global's and these are pretty
interesting questions and I'm definitely
supportive of exploring them I've been
working on them myself partially from
the web side I am Dominic denna Cola
from the chrome team at Google thank you
and I want to mention especially the
efforts from our colleagues at Apple who
have put together a proposal titled
JavaScript standard library focused on
let's let's add some of these new
standard library features as built-in
modules instead of built-in Global's
and we're looking into several concrete
proposals in tc39 about features to add
to the to the standard library you're
heard and terah's talked earlier today
about recent recent additions like
object from entries and there are other
things that we're considering putting
maybe in built-in modules or maybe in
the traditional way as properties of
objects that are connected to the global
we're looking into temporal which is a
new date/time library which could be
make it so that you don't need to use
moment we're looking into possibly a
UUID standard library or library for
iterator helper methods like inner tools
in Python as well as as well as methods
on set and map and Whedon
I think we were missing a bunch of
things that would be useful to have in
the standard library and so it would be
great to have more more help from from
contributors about this yeah I just
wanted to mention that you know some of
these library type features have been
some of the most successful proposals in
getting through the process more quickly
so you know I mentioned that features
can take years but we've also had
features that take you know six months
or eight months because they're they're
kind of just you know oh yeah everybody
agrees we should have a from entries
method on object we should have a
finally method on promised that type of
thing the last thing I want to add is
that when we talk about the JavaScript
standard library I think it's important
not just to look at things that come
from this group at T's 39 but also
things that are just available across
the ecosystem and that ship with
JavaScript runtimes everywhere and that
includes things like URL or text encoder
which are in both browsers and in node
and in other runtimes if they wish to
implement them there's a bunch of
examples like that yeah and you know
you'll hear more about the integration
of URL and text encoder and and other
browser web api is in node.js in in
Joey's talk later today but I think
dominic and I are really trying to break
down the barriers between different
standards groups and make sure that we
can all work together to build a good
javascript standard library
Thank You Dominic and thank you Dan
moving on to our next question
we have a question that's been given to
us anonymously asking often we're having
discussions that are unrelated to
proposals and are related to like larger
questions around tc39 and there doesn't
seem to be a place for them but yes
discuss is not really being used is
there any plan to improve this funny you
should mention we are currently working
on having a new discourse instance it
gives us an opportunity to be able to
figure out what people really are
talking about so that delegates who have
limited time I mean we also have day
jobs we do this you know in addition can
really engage with what the community
wants to talk about and it'll give us
the ability to have those conversations
in public and hopefully be less of a
black box to people because we we really
do want to engage the people it's just
hard to find each other when what we
talk about can be so asset Eric oh we
had a little thing with Mike but that
was all right yeah okay actually we have
another slide here if you want to check
that out here's a QR code and you can go
to that directly I'm going to leave that
on for a second thank you okey moving on
to the next question and we've had this
the last two years it's on the pattern
matching proposal Martin Willian
Martin's asks I've not seen any movement
on the pattern matching proposal is this
proposal in an idle state also if this
proposal lands as a statement well what
will be the heuristics to decide when
using it or a chain of if-else do you
think having pattern matching as an
expression would be more beneficial so
that's the first question that's a
that's a big question hi I'm Kat Martin
I am part of NPM Inc and I am also one
of the co champions and co-authors of
the pattern matching proposal the
proposals kind of stalled right now like
as we talked about like these things
take a lot of time right now
sometimes what it's at right now is it's
waiting to be proposed for stage two so
as soon as I get it ready to like show
up at a meeting and actually ask for
stage 2 then it might hopefully step up
there as far as the the statement versus
versus expression thing that's a much
harder problem we have then actually
proposed a really interesting solution
to the to the statement and expression
problem for those of you who don't know
like the the pattern matching proposal
currently it's only a statement so it
doesn't allow you to like directly
assign from the pattern matching thing
because it has like economics that are
more similar to other things like if and
else and all that stuff do you want to
say something about what you proposed
it's just really hard to evolve the
grammar of JavaScript there's there's a
lot of things in it already and there's
a lot of things that sort of happened
implicitly so to sort of work through
this their their various different
solutions and that's that's sort of why
a lot of these proposals take time at
tc39 because for a big proposal like
pattern matching we need to consider a
lot of different alternatives to work
through these kind of technical issues
and find something that's really going
to be good again all right and we have a
second question about this from last
year
Leonard caulk asks what are your
thoughts on reducing the capabilities of
the pattern matching proposal expression
to statement in favor of language
cohesion um so I guess I kind of
answered this already didn't I you might
have sorry I was I think I might've
answered this already um you know the
idea is is I don't like the idea that
it's a statement I want to get something
out there because I'd rather have
a statement than no pattern-matching at
all and my hope is that once we have it
as a statement we can use that as
justification to bring more conditionals
into expressions so that maybe we can
start discussing say bringing if-else in
to bring an expression and then the the
the trouble is like the semantics in the
language don't make it particularly easy
to say what the result of a of a
statement like thing will be if use an
expression position and kind of like
there's one proposal that's out there
answering those questions and I kind of
wanted that proposal to at least start
exploring that before giving a solid
answer that's the new expressions
proposal whether or not you it's
required to wrap it with you it's up to
the future but we need to answer the
same problem regardless of of what we
use thank you excuse me
oh no I have a mic right now okay next
question
moving right along into questions
surrounding language design so we had
one question from Marvin Hagen Meister
are there any this is also from last
year are there any long-term goals
what's the bigger picture for javascript
in the next five years
just one hi i'm xu i work at bloomberg
so javascript is many things to many
people
including all of you in in the in the
community here that is the same for us
in committee it is many things to many
of us in committee we have different
personal visions personal aesthetics for
what we want the language to be and
perhaps we're also constrained by what
our companies would like the language to
be for its use case and it is a
committee language so it is not a one
author language where it's much easier
to kind of exercise your singular vision
for better or for worse so the answer is
it's really hard to say what the five
year picture or what the big picture for
what javascript is right now it's we're
trying always trying to work out a
consensus between the many different
visions that people bring to committee
and I want to kind of
that the usual response to this when you
hear this is while it's going to be a
mess and it's going to be just full of
compromises is gonna be things of full
of things that people don't like but I
think in practice it's JavaScript's is
is eminently useful it keeps getting
more and more popular it's used
basically everywhere on the front end on
the back end and I think you know we've
done a decent job and I hope we can do a
better job at bringing more cohesion but
there is going to be no singular vision
going forward it's going to be very
difficult to get that but I hope to have
consensus on practicality and what's
most important thing at the time thank
you the next question we have is about
how transpiling impacts javascript and
the specific question is as follows
typescript reason ml pure script babel
javascript has become the target of many
compilers how does this fact influence
your work on the job on the language in
general from so I'm Henry I work on that
well yeah I think JavaScript is what it
is today because of CoffeeScript tracer
being able to use features before
they're implemented I think that's an
opportunity for the whole community to
be involved whether it's making new
proposals you know testing them out when
they're in early stages although we warn
against doing that in production and
yeah just being able to be a part of you
don't have to be on the committee but
being able to be involved yeah thank you
and moving on to the next one from Soren
Bruce Frank I hope I pronounced that
correctly I doubt it when writing new
features where do you look most for
inspiration is it other languages which
ones in that case or is it mostly driven
from requests by the community very
quickly again the answer is many things
to many people but for me personally
I've always very much wanted to bring
new capabilities to the language in the
web that it could not do before like
what we have done with shared array
buffers to bring kind of threads in
shared memory programming to the web and
as we hope to do soon we crafts
yep definitely one a second what you
said but I want to say from my
perspective as somebody represent the
chrome team we were interested in what
makes programming on the web easier and
so when we think about like new features
were like what are people commonly doing
you know what shows up popular what's a
popular pattern for writing websites and
that is hard because of JavaScript today
an example proposal which I kind of
started but but never really followed
through on is something called blocks
where it's like oh we want it to be
easier for people to write web workers
like inline in JavaScript because we
think concurrency is important on the
web things like that is one motivating
factor that at least one member of the
committee tries to use to judge to
govern this process and we're gonna have
to round off to a rarely last question
which is from thank you so much for that
answer Dominic which is Mark I'm not
going to try with all the new operators
and features that are being added to
JavaScript is there a risk that the
language will have too cryptic of syntax
for new developers I'm very much in
favor of them but web development being
approachable is a very big boon I guess
we're almost out of time I'll try to
answer this as quickly as possible but
we do consider that very strongly with
every proposal we have a notion of a
syntax budget that basically you know
exemplifies the idea that there is only
so much syntax you can take before you
completely overwhelmed in trying to use
a language and so we want that to be
comfortable we don't want to overshoot
that but we do want to make use of new
syntax where it really is worthwhile
well have a couple of quick one back and
forth sometimes adding just a little bit
of new syntax can make programming
easier like a lot of programmers are
excited about the optional chaining
proposal where you use question mark dot
instead of done and then if the object
is undefined it still works so sometimes
even adding new syntax can make things
easier to program so we consider this as
a trade-off not a absolute thank you so
thank you very much to everyone who's on
the panel and thank you all for being
such a wonderful audience
as always we are looking for different
ways to help people participate in the
process and also to help us get the best
data one thing that we are doing right
now it's an experiment that's currently
running oh I forgot that slide was there
we currently have an experiment running
if you want to participate in it here
this is very finicky here is the link
please feel free to click to go to this
URL and take the survey it's going to
help us figure out whether or not
experimental data works for the
committee process and that is all for
our panel thank you so much everyone
[Applause]
[Music]